Russian President Vladimir
Putin today making it official.
He just formally suspended
Russia's involvement
in its last remaining nuclear arms
control treaty with the United States.
That move
coming after a rare admission
from President Putin
about losses on the battlefield
in Ukraine
and pneumonia.
Unfortunately,
there are losses in our ranks
the leadership of the FSB
must do everything to provide
additional support
to the families of our fallen comrades.
On that battlefield today,
the eastern city of Bermuda
is a flash point as it is the landscape
calling the battle, quote, challenging.
Ukrainian soldiers
paint a much more dire picture to CNN,
saying the situation
is, quote,
100% worse than what's being reported.
And as Melissa Bell
is live for us on the ground
in the Ukrainian capital of Kiev,
Melissa, what's the latest
Well, hellish is
the way
another Ukrainian soldier described it
to CNN.
John, the picture they paint
is really pretty horrendous.
What you're talking about is a town
that's been the subject of fighting
for so many weeks now.
The conditions
there have worsened as
the ground has thawed.
There's flooding in some areas,
impassable roads and others.
But those Ukrainian soldiers
that are
saying, look, we're holding firm
despite Russian claims,
they say Russian forces,
even though they've been sending
their most battle-hardened regular
but also
volunteer mercenaries
to try and break
through Ukrainian defenses
The Ukrainian soldiers
saying
they simply have not encircled us yet
and that there are still two roads
through which they continue
to get their much needed supplies,
even though they're
coming under enemy fire.
But really a very grim picture
being painted about
what those Ukrainian forces are facing
as they try and hold firm now.
For several days
now, we've been hearing
growingly desperate pleas for more
allied equipment
and help in the shape of F-16s.
Now, of course,
Washington's ruled those out.
But we do know that
there is other weaponry coming online
fairly quickly.
We've just been hearing
from an American official
speaking to the Armed Services
Committee, saying
that it is some 4000 Ukrainian soldiers
that are now being trained,
not just the United States.
But in Europe, across Europe,
on the Patriot systems,
for instance, on the leopard tanks.
And, of course,
those are expected to make
a big difference.
The question is just how quickly
when they will be usable here in Ukraine
and what happens
in the meantime, specifically
for those soldiers
who are very bravely trying
to hold out against increasing
increasingly determined
and numerous Russian troops.
John Sabel live for us in Kiev.
Melissa, thank you so much.
Let's get some perspective now from the
lieutenant general, Mark Hertling.
He said served as commanding general,
the U.S.
Army, Europe
and the Seventh Army general.
Grateful for your time,
especially on this day.
You just heard Melissa explain
what we're hearing from soldiers
on the ground
President Zelensky himself
calls it challenging.
If I could ask the controller
to put the map back up.
When you look at back mood
and where it is in southeastern Ukraine,
if you're in the room trying to debate
military strategy here.
Is it
smart maybe to give it up
and then come back and fight another day
or is holding it of some strategic
whether it's strategic on the battlefield
or strategic
in terms of public opinion,
public morale, to keep it
Yes, John.
All of the above.
What we're talking about
is an inconsequential city.
Before the war,
it was a population of about 70,000.
It's a small
area, small city on the intersection
of a couple of roads
and near some railroads for resupply.
It is not strategically important,
but it has become
strategically imperative
to hold by the Ukrainians
and certainly by the Russians
trying to take it.
I would equate this somewhat
like Bastogne during World War Two,
the Battle of the Bulge,
the city itself was not critical,
but holding on to it.
The Ukrainians
saying we are not going to give this up.
We're going to suck
a whole lot more Russians into this
into this malaise
and cause more problems is important
to them, certainly.
And the Russians need a victory
that they have not been able to achieve.
John,
how long have we been talking about
the city of back move?
It's been months now
and the Ukrainians continue
to hold on to it.
And so in that context,
you talk about Putin could use a win,
even if it's a small one.
When you hear it's quite obvious
that Russia has suffered
huge losses on the battlefield
over the last year.
Now we're into the first month
of the second year of this war.
Yet to hear
Putin say it
so publicly acknowledging,
what does that tell you?
Who's that aimed for in your view?
Is it aimed at trying to keep up
military morale, saying,
I hear it,
I understand
you're hurting
and some of your families
have suffered profoundly?
Is it about public opinion?
All of the above
Well, it's all of the above also.
But but here's
the context of Putin's speech today.
Today,
he was talking to the FSB,
which is the organization
that followed on to the KGB,
some a group that he was once a part of.
So when he was talking about casualties
was just one part of that speech.
He was also telling the FBI, FSB
increased the
supervision and
oversight of the Russian population.
And he was doing this on a day
when Ukrainian drones were flying over
Russian cities, by my account,
12 different cities.
A few days after there was a successful
Ukrainian Russians
strike against that Russian
air AWACS plane in Belarus.
And and the fact of the matter is
that he's saying
Putin is seeing more
and more
demonstrations against what's happening,
and that's going to increase
as more and more dead
bodies come home to Russian mothers.
So what Putin is basically saying today
is, yeah,
we're having problems on the battlefield
and he's telling the FSB, increase
the things you're doing to put down
the Russian population,
the Russian citizens.
So it is not a good sign for Mr.
Putin today, in my view.
He's having some problems back home.
General Hertling, as always, sir,
thank you for your time.
Vladimir Putin delivered a major speech
a short time ago to the FSB.
That is Russia's
Federal Security Service.
Putin admitted that members of the FSB
have actually been killed in Ukraine,
and he urged the intelligence agency
to step up its work to counter
Western spy agencies.
That speech
comes as intense fighting continues
around the town of Buck
in eastern Ukraine.
Ukrainian forces say that
the situation is getting dire
and they are running out of ammunition
Let's bring in Steve Hall.
He's a national security analyst
and a
former CIA chief of Russia operations.
So, Steve,
I wonder,
what was your takeaway
from Putin's speech this morning?
Was the point here to kind of rally
the troops
at a really tough moment in this war?
Yes, certainly that's part of it.
I mean, I think there's a lot going on
in the speech, a lot
that Putin wanted to try to accomplish.
First and foremost
was to try to increase the morale
inside the FSB
the one of the major security services,
probably the strongest in Russia.
They do have folks on on the ground
in Ukraine,
like many intelligence
services, security services.
They had a wartime
sort of paramilitary capability,
both collection
and also to conduct attacks and so forth.
But as Putin alluded to,
they also have a very,
very important role
that they need to continue
playing inside of Russia.
And that's the counterintelligence piece
that he mentioned several times in
the speech.
And he also urged the FSB
to step up their operations
to counteract
Western intelligence services,
who he says has boosted their operations.
So I wonder, I mean, should the West,
the US
and NATO's nations be concerned
about what this means
for them in the near term?
I don't think it's a real change.
These things are sort of going on
in the background
and Putin mentioned them in his speech,
but at all, it's
one big ball of of responsibilities
that the FSB had inside of Russia.
So when he
when putting out
first of counterintelligence, he's
not just talking about
the work of Western intelligence services
and other intelligence services,
although that's part of it.
What he's really concerned about
is dissidents inside of Russia.
And there's an entire center
inside the FSB
that is responsible
for not only monitoring,
but also
taking care of eliminating
or as the Russians say
it, liquidating dissidents.
And he's very, very concerned,
I think, about that
because of how poorly the war is going.
He's got to monitor it
very, very carefully.
Yeah.
And they're taking a lot of casualties,
those casualties going back to Russia.
What effect all that will have?
I think we are definitely all
looking to see.
Thank you, Steve Hall,
for all of that analysis.